la moitié de la population du venezuela
vit sous le seuil de la pauvreté et 80%
d'entre elles souffrent d'insécurité
alimentaire et des pénuries de
médicaments selon deux des grandes
universités du pays
l'inflation est de 1 million 300 mille
pour cent
comment le pays le plus riche d'amérique
latine avec les plus grandes réserves de
pétrole du monde at il pu tomber aussi
bas
nous sommes victimes d'une guerre
économique dirigée par les états unis
répète le président nicholas maduro qui
nous empêche d'importer des vivres et
des médicaments
arrêter les mensonges dit son adversaire
[Applaudissements]
mais d'éveiller ça c'est la société
nationale pétrolière du venezuela a
servi à nicolas maduro et son groupe de
gangsters à s'enrichir et à détruire
l'industrie pétrolière l'ex-procureur
luisa ortega explique le tour de passe
passe
c'est facile si on contrôle l'entrée des
pétrodollars et le système de changes à
taux variable instauré par hugo chavez
en 2003 il suffit de prêter des bolivar
ap dvs à epb vs allez rembourse en
dollars cette absurde mais c'est un des
mécanismes du blanchiment d'argent
luisa ortega fidèle d'hugo chavez a
servi comme concurrent général depuis
2007 puis sous maduro jusqu'à 2017
lorsqu'elles commencent à dénoncer la
corruption des principaux dirigeants
elle est harcelée on l'empêchent
d'accéder à ses bureaux
elle croit la fuite avec son mari le
député rayman ferrer un autre proche
d'hugo chavez
elle est destitué et on ordonne son
arrestation
manassero et nicolás maduro réclame le
code rouge d'interpol
voici ce qui a provoqué la rupture ce
qui a fait mal c'est son enquête sur
l'affairé de brecht la compagnie
brésilienne de construction au coeur du
scandale de corruption de la petrobras
qui a touché presque toute l'amérique
latine
luis ortega prend la fuite et se
réfugier en colombie décisions
difficiles quand ta vie est en jeu
tu n'as pas le choix sa vie a été mise
en danger par ces dénonciations sur le
scandale aux deux brèches l'état
vénézuélien a versé 35 millions de
dollars à eau de brecht pour une
douzaine de grands travaux qui n'ont
jamais été terminée 13 chantiers
inachevés ou à peine commencé un
monument à la corruption mine dont la
corruption au de brecht a avoué avoir
versé des pots de vin d'un total de 98
millions de dollars sous chavez et mado
qui selon elle a touché plus de 50
millions de dollars
contrairement aux autres pays touchés
par le scandale
il n'y a pas d' enquête au venezuela
mais luis ortega continue à monter ses
dossiers et n'hésite pas à désigner les
principaux responsables
nicolás maduro et son épouse cilia
florès nicolas des l'cie rodrigues vice
présidente et son frère le ministre
aurait rodrigues et plusieurs autres
dont le numéro deux du régime
diosdado cabello à cela elle ajoute des
hauts gradés de l'armée
parmi les 2000 généraux dans la gestion
des sociétés d'état mais aussi dans le
trafic de drogue
on l'appelle el cartel de los soles
le cartel des soleils à cause d un signe
de leur uniforme
les principaux membres du gouvernement
ma d'euros figurent sur des listes
américaine qui les lie au narcotrafic
wyss ortega souligne la condamnation à
18 ans de prison pour trafic de drogue à
new york de deux neveux très proche de
la première dame cilia florès dans le
dossier on apprend que le chargement de
la drogue se faisait dans la zone
présidentiel de l'aéroport de maiquetia
le mec était un pur nicolás maduro il
s'agit d'une adaptation de
l'impérialisme sur son épouse karine
pèlerine mon combat quelles que soient
les bras les avions de pbs à sont
utilisés pour beaucoup de choses y
compris du temps pour le trafic de
drogue tout en rejetant les accusations
de luis ortega et en l'accusant
elle-même de corruption nicolás maduro a
lancé une grande purge dans la compagnie
pétrolière pdvsa pour corruption par
otis quant à la collection luis ortega a
déposé tous ces dossiers sous forme de
plainte et diverses instances
internationales elle espère que justice
sera rendue
lorsque le venezuela aura retrouvé ce
qu'elle souhaite démocratie liberté et
droits humains dans un état de droit